great to see you bob thank you yeah
everyone's delighted to see you as
always
it hasn't been too long hasn't been too
long that's right we've hung out a
couple of times it's always a great
christmas it was
it was like you came to my house at
christmas and everyone
freaked out and some some big people
came by and
everyone was like it's bob newhart and
it's i said no he's an impersonator
i hired him for the evening and uh you
got a b-plus
you know i get that because like when i
go on the road and
you go to detroit or you go to
philadelphia whatever
and the question i i get people come up
and say
you sure look like them yeah
and you let it go with that you go yeah
yeah i've been i've been told that a lot
yeah yeah you just keep moving this is
unbelievable huge anniversary
uh well first of all 60 years in show
business congratulations that's just an
epic
achievement but then
you have a more uh personal anniversary
coming up is that right
well in uh in in january
my wife and i jenny and i will be
married
56 years wow
a lovely woman yes lovely one you know
what
uh you guys have always just seemed so
perfect for each other how did you meet
her you know sometimes when you're in
show business it's hard to re meet the
right people
how did you meet her she's amazing well
um
actually buddy hacker do you remember
buddy hack a great comedian yeah
yeah everybody happy to meet you he
buddy he said to me
uh he said yeah bobby he said you're
you're a catalytic right
i think we have a picture of buddy i
just want to see we have to see a photo
theory isn't mad mad mad mad mad mad
world i think but anyway so that's
exactly how he talked he said what
she said yeah you're catholic right and
i said yeah buddy i'm kathy
it's okay i gotta go i got a girl for
you
but she's going with another guy but
i don't think that she's right for him
so
i think you know you i'll pick you up on
a blind date and then
then you'll get married and then you you
know you have kids and
and maybe you'll name one one of them
buddies
that was the deal if it works out and
you have kids you name one of them buddy
we did you did
one of the girls
yeah i know her she's great she's great
sounds just like that